hello everyone while we're waiting for
round four of the London chest classic I
decided to show you a game by two
magicians I already showed one game
played between Miguel Italian there are
sheet mesh MIDI note I will put a link
in the description below so you can
check it out as in that video I said
something more about Nash Medina and his
relationship would make hotel so don't
want to repeat most of the things I said
you know you're free to check it out if
you're looking for some more info and
that game this being here it was played
in the USSR championship in 1957 and as
it often was when Thailand is medina
played in the same tournament Nash
Medina of beach towel and towel beat
everyone else so this is a this was the
case in the 1957 USSR championship tile
one clear first place with 13 and a half
points ahead of Paul Karason David
Bronstein
but you know it's always it's always
amazing to watch Anuj Medina play
against all two of them play the
countless blades games and you know a
lot of unofficial games but officially
they played 4 tournament games and the
result in the end was three to one in a
German Dino's favor I always said that
Nash Medina had the white pieces in all
four games so you know it would always
seem interesting to see what would
happen if tall had the white pieces in
some of the games but nevertheless all
the four games are quite amazing this is
the second game I'm showing you and
eventually I will show all four so let's
see this game Nash Medina has the white
pieces and he plays efore we have east
six by tau tau goes for the French
defense d4 d5 now and the Knight to c3
Bishop to b4 now the vinegar variation B
5 now the advance variation C 5 and
Bishop to D to banish Medina and this is
a I mean in all my years of playing
chess I've never met this move over the
board in tournaments play rather you'll
pretty much always face a3 and then
either Bishop captures on c3
be captors on c3 and 97 or if black is
interested and you know some adventurous
play maybe I'll see even Bishop to a5
and then after b4c captures on d4 and
Queen to g4 with some interesting play
football for both sides but after c5
finish Medina plays Bishop to d2
Knight to e7 and a 3 now Bishop captures
and Bishop captures on c3 and ok now
white did manage to you know keep his
pawn structure intact and now this
Bishop captures on c3 and you know it's
okay for white b6 by tau
since stall already has a quite an
expansion here on the Queen side he
wants to develop his light square bishop
and he should be okay
b4 immediately Rasheed challenges this
Queen to c7 we have Knight to f3 Knight
d7 Bishop to e2 preparing to Castle
Knight to c6 and news Medina of castles
star castles be captures and c5 be
captures on c5 d captures on c5 and
night C captures on e5 Knight captures
on e5 Knight captures on e5 and we have
Queen to d4 threatening to capture the
night and already if you if you play
well there's really nothing you can't
play here for black one there's only one
good move for black or you lose the
night you can't move the knight because
this Bishop and queen will be
threatening checkmate on g7 so only move
for tal that works here is f6 protecting
the night and now the night will be able
to move f4 now kicking the night unites
the c6 would attempt on the Queen and
Queen to e3 and that was for rook to d8
now tau is preparing to push
d4 and win a piece here rook a to d1
protecting and now e5 and again tau is
ready to push d4 we have F captures on
e5 f captures on e5 and Bishop to b5 now
knowledge matino is a indirectly stop
stopping d4
would a tactic if Tom would play d4 here
then Queen to b4 is winning the game
after if you play something like D
captors on c3 then simply Queen captures
on c6 if you play Queen captures on c6
rook chapter 78 and this is checkmate
only move Queen has the block and then
rook captures and it's it's game over
so after Bishop to b5 tile first played
Bishop to b7 now protecting the c6
Knight and queens the g3 again with the
ideas of with some threats on g7 kind of
stopping d4 and e4 rook to d7 preparing
to bring the other rook into the game
and also adding more protection to the
g7 pawn rook to F 2 we have rook to e8
now and h3 making some breeding bringing
room for the king
Bishop to a8 now Bishop to a for
preparing Bishop to b3 in getting the
bishop and this beautiful diagonal in
some variations and it's starting heart
for tal to find the move here in this
position if tall would play something
like e 4 then Queen captures and c7 rook
captures and rook captures and e-file
this loses a pawn and and refuge is
winning the game here so after Bishop a4
even d4 doesn't work now simply rook D
to F 1 and again white is much better if
you capture the bishop you get better to
b3 check and you have to block rope to
f7 if you move the King you're getting
rope to f8 checkmate so I have to look
to f7 and captures captures captures
this is game over there is no defense
against Queen captures you can't prolong
with g6 but then Queen h4 and again with
the same ideas so after Bishop to a4
towel plays Bishop back to b7 repeating
the move and saying to Rashid well what
do you what do you got
Rashid plays King to h1 as tall didn't
really make any progress with his move
so I placed into h1 to me
maybe stop many unpleasant checks along
this diagonal in the future top plays
Bishop but back to eight again waiting
for a sheet to show what he's planning
and now rook to f8 and here now Rasheed
is probably preparing to double up rooks
and the F file and it all has to do
something and towel decides to go for
efore he gives up a pawn to create a
passed pawn of his own Queen captures on
c7 rook captures in c7 and now Rashid of
course captures the d5 pawn and tal
pushes III and okay tile gave up a pawn
but now he has this strong passed pawn
on e3 Rashid plays rook to d7 and okay
he does have some threats and g7 pawn
but you can't capture with the rook
since the broken c7 is guarding it towel
plays e - now threatening to grab this
rook with check but here actually Rashid
has a forced mate checkmate in four
moves and Rashid of course finds it
Bishop to b3 check and now it's over if
you play King to h8 you get Bishop
captures on g7 this is checkmate if you
play King to f8 then Bishop captures on
g7 is checkmate just as well
so after this Bishop to b3 rook to e6
blocking now Bishop captures on e6 and
now the King has to go King to f8 and
Bishop captures on g7 this was the last
move of the game in this position
Michael tal resigned the game there is
only one square for his King after King
to e8 now Bishop to f7 and this is
checkmate and this is this is quite a
formation of white pieces either the
roofs are doubled and the bishops are
also doubled that's that's a very nice
Bishop repair even though even though
tile is so close to actually you know
winning material and probably the game
but you know it's checkmate and the game
is over so yeah this is like I said the
second game you've seen on my channel
between these two great magicians Rashid
nazar Medina and Michael Tao
you're welcome to check out my previous
video with these two great masters and
like I always say when I show a Russian
is MIDI no game for those of you who
haven't do check out Jessica Fischer's
video on Russian - MIDI note it's like
it's the best chess video on the whole
internet so those of you who haven't
seen it just right Jessica Fischer -
MIDI no in YouTube you know grab some
popcorn and you know some refreshments
and enjoy it it lasts about half an hour
so you know but I've seen it like 20
times it's like it's like the best chess
video ever so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I will eventually
show the other two games and for last I
will save the one that towel wins
against Rashid I would like to thank you
on a sauce long for contributed to my
channel thanks a lot - really appreciate
it as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank y'all for watching and
I will see you soon
hopefully with not another draw from the
London chess classic